if this doesn't show you that I'm
desperate to have a minimalist design
if this doesn't show you that I'm wildly
desperate to have a minimalist design
approach to my YouTube videos but
clearly don't know how to do it I don't
know what does hello my name is grace
Helbig if you did not know now you do
know and if you were not subscribed you
should subscribe to my channel because
Halloween is right around the corner and
so many people love dressing up like
Disney Princesses for great reason
they're beautiful I was gonna say human
beings but that's not what they are
they're fictional characters great job
polarizing the Disney fanatical audience
helping they're not real and there are
so many tutorials online of how you can
create your own Disney princess
Halloween costume but I wanted to give
you a tutorial for something different
I wanted to create the fictionalized
version of a Disney Princesses daughters
Halloween costume and is difficult and
complicated as the concept of this video
is to explain it will probably be
equally difficult if not more
complicated on Halloween to explain to
other partygoers or Halloween people
that you come across what you actually
are so best of luck recreating these
have fun with it
just have fun right chew deeply also
these costumes on just an aesthetic
level might be kind of complicated to
recreate because they're basically all
items that I already owned and just
tried to really force into a costume
scenario without further and get French
sorry I'm so smart
here are my Disney princess daughter
Disney Princesses daughter Halloween
costumes for Disney Princesses daughters
Disney Princess solder Disney here
without here are my Disney princess
daughter Halloween costumes sure this
first couple daughter Belle from Beauty
in the beach island beast and you can
imagine that their daughter would be
super strong and have a crazy fit body
like a wrestler whose pecs look a lot
like boobs there we go no doubt she'd
have some feast like features so I took
these Bearpaw slippers for your feet and
put them on my hands she'd also have a
constant struggle to balance her
masculine and feminine side so don't be
afraid to use some overly masculine and
feminine props I'm using protein powder
and these things and there you have it
our next costume is the daughter of my
royal and Prince Eric Wow no doubt that
girl's going to inherit Prince Eric's
classic style so opted for a masculine
white button-up and a navy blue blazer
on top of that I threw on some glasses
for sophistication and because you'll
probably have terrible eyesight because
her mom was a fish and her dad as a
human with that you got to get the
classic red hair this is the closest wig
I had to red hair cause speaking of a
half-human half-fish child there's no
doubt you'll have some weird picked up
abnormality I chose to represent shark
growing out of the chest neck also
should probably have asthma because of
the fish human-hybrid and because her
mom said most of her life poorly
managing her beautiful hair she's
probably growing up to be an excellent
successful hair stylist also severely
depressed this next costume is a grand
Royal Sleeping Beauty I really Philip
whoa no doubt their daughters gonna be a
caffeine junkie dedicated to making a
difference since her mom slept for the
majority of her life she's into
protesting so much so that she actually
died in
a hunger strike for no one knows moving
on to the donor over put that bear eyes
there's no doubt Rapunzel's daughter is
going to stay away from ever having long
hair also a rebellion of her mother's
own solitude and dependency on a man
she's gonna be a very strong-willed
individual fighting for her own
independence something like that there's
also a rumor that Rapunzel actually had
twins but one of them had to stay in the
shadows
the last costume is the dog I also come
frozen my real ever she decides to marry
oh the daughter of an ice queen who has
separated herself from the rest of
society in a self-made Ice Palace in
which no one is allowed in physically or
emotionally what could that costume
possibly look like there you go there
were my Disney princess daughter
Halloween costumes let me know which
ones you really enjoyed and if you have
ideas for others because the Internet is
about sharing information and please
only share with me that you liked this
video by giving it a thumbs up and
subscribing to my channel if you didn't
do it at the beginning and that's it get
out of here go on with your lives save
yourselves
I don't know